[Applause]
wow thank you very much as a big crowd
of people
[Applause]
well hello Pickens and hello to South
Carolina it's great to be with you we've
had great success together
I don't know if you know it but those
crowds are going all the way back into
whatever the hell Street you have back
there whatever that street is they've
passed it
there's nowhere else I'd rather be to
kick off the Fourth of July weekend then
right here on Main Street with thousands
of proud hard-working South Carolina
Patriots who believe in God family and
Country do we all believe in God family
and Country I think so
let me Begin by wishing each and every
one of you a very happy Independence Day
it's big day
we need our independence back to be
honest with you
nearly two and a half centuries ago
Brave American Patriots risked their
lives for the Majestic cause of freedom
their names entered history as Heroes
and Legends they are indeed Legends
they want to delete our Legends we're
not letting them delete our Legends
we're not letting them delete General
Pickens either that I can tell you
there will be no deletion of General
Pickens
but names like George Washington Thomas
Jefferson Benjamin Franklin Patrick
Henry and South Carolina's own Francis
Marion and the great General
the great General Andrew Pickens he's
become very famous today I have to be
hot as this thing is all over the world
Avid broadcast look at all the fake news
back there
it's all over the world
I hope they don't go back to their
spreads where they're all losing lots of
money because they don't have
credibility anymore and so I say let's
look at Andrew Pickens let me see what
did he do wrong let's change the name
let's change don't let him change
anything don't let them change
when they want to change the name of
George Washington they've taken the name
of George Washington off over a hundred
schools throughout the country these
people are sick
when they want to get rid of the
Jefferson Memorial that's not happening
but today everything
having to do with those courageous
Americans who fought for us and
sacrificed so strongly is indeed being
destroyed under crooked Joe Biden and he
is crooked as hell isn't it
[Applause]
you know I've been hitting him much
differently than I have because I've
always respected the office and then
when they indicted me for nothing I said
now that loves are off now we have to
say it like it is he's a crook
under crooked Joe Biden I never called
him that I took the name away from
Hillary Clinton we call her beautiful
Hillary now and because I don't it was
crooked Hillary now it's crooked Joe
because it's a much more appropriate
name right now for this man who's just
destroying our country under crooked Joe
Biden millions and millions of illegal
aliens are streaming across our border
Main Street is being crushed by
catastrophic inflation our constitution
is being ripped to shreds our children
are being taught to hate our great
Heroes hate them you're going to hate
Abraham Lincoln you're going to hate
George Washington
men are
competing in women's sports how about
that one
[Applause]
murders gang members and bloodthirsty
killers are being set loose on innocent
people and Joe Biden is stumbling us
into the brink of World War III because
he has no idea what the hell he's doing
[Music]
while starting
and when you think of
when you think of what's going on with
Russia you know Russia now is at a point
where they better make the right
decision
because we're in a course toward World
War III and the weaponry
is impossible have you ever saw the kind
of power that the kind of destructive
force and we have a man who's grossly
incompetent who's representing us and if
you look at the leaders of the world
these people are at the top of their
game president XI and Kim Jong-un and I
could name almost every country but we
have somebody that's not at all
but while stating twice this week as an
example that Russia
is losing the war to Iraq
twice not you know you can make mistakes
on occasion
even Lindsay down here Senator Lindsey
Graham We Love Senator we're gonna act
we're gonna love him
you're gonna love him
I know it's half and half but what I
need some of those liberal votes he's
always there to help me get them okay
we got some pretty liberal people but
he's good he's good we know the good
ones we know the bad ones do we got some
real bad ones but even he makes mistakes
on occasion but you can't make a mistake
by calling Ukraine Iraq
and then you certainly can't do it a
second time because there's something
wrong with the help of everyone here
today we're going to win the South
Carolina primary seven months from now
big
and on Election Day 2024 we're going to
evict we are going to evict crooked Joe
Biden from the white house we're going
to bring our country back we are going
to take back our country we're going to
make America great again that's what we
need make America
great again
the fake news media has finally started
to admit
what we all knew Joe Biden is the most
corrupt president in American history by
far it's not even close
he's a criminal and a liar
who sold his office to
foreign countries and many other people
you take a look at what's going on all
of the stuff goes into the stuff he
calls it goes into family pockets
and it comes from many cases very bad
third world actors and nobody thought
they were going to get caught with all
of their phony corporations that they
set up the only problem is those people
don't like to report on it but they're
actually having to start it's very
interesting
I'm just not sure I want to run against
anybody else I sort of like this one
and by the way we're leading him by a
lot but just think
just think of the massive Biden
corruption unveiled in the past few
weeks alone
according to Representatives James Comer
and Jim Jordan are doing a fantastic job
by the way
at least nine Biden family members were
paid vast sums of money through 20
different shell companies for no
legitimate reason at all they can't
figure it out while
crooked Joe was vice president he was
using that as a
cash machine
in addition we learned the FBI is
explosive evidence that Joe Biden took
bribes from Ukraine yet the corrupt FBI
is out of control not only covered it up
they stayed silent while crazy Nancy
Pelosi little Adam Schiff how about that
beauty little Adam's here
and the radical Democrats impeached me
they impeached me
but that was just the beginning because
they also invited me a couple of years
later
for asking questions about
the Biden bribery scam just happened to
ask it turned out I was right
this is a sick nest of people that needs
to be cleaned out and cleaned out
immediately turned out I was right
it turned out I was right I had to go
through two impeachments and I was right
on both of them and it's been proven and
especially with the laptop from hell
it's been proven it's been right there
right in front of their eyes last week
an IRS whistleblower revealed that
crooked Joe sat in a room while his son
Hunter messaged a Chinese Communist
Party top official
and he said I quote I am sitting here
with my father
sleepy Joe
and we would like to
and by the way he may not be asleep as
we thought you know based on all this
stuff
and we would like to understand
with the commitment made
what has happened why has it not been
fulfilled why haven't you sent us the
money
tell the director that I would like to
resolve this right now before it gets
out of hand and now means tonight I
didn't know he was a tough guy he is
they are with with our money they're not
with
our nation because they're giving it
away to other countries and if I get a
call or text from anyone involved and
this other than you Zang top person or
the chairman I will make certain that
between the man sitting next to me
that's dead
hi dad remember
he said he was the he said he was the
smartest person he's ever met
by the way at some time does does Joe
Biden say you know there's something's
just not working out very well at some
point but it won't be it won't matter if
the Press doesn't catch it remember that
but the man sitting next to me and every
person he knows you will regret not
following Marie
my rejection and direction
I'm sitting here waiting for the call
and he says he wants it right now I'm
sitting waiting for the call with my
father within 10 days the Biden's
collected 5.1 million dollars from China
for no reason whatsoever they didn't do
anything
once again Trump was right Trump was
right that these hats Trump was right
about everything I don't know about
everything but we were right about a lot
Marjorie right a lot
Joe Biden is corrupt and Joe Biden is a
very compromised president
he's being paid off just like a common
criminal gets paid off just a more
sophisticated Manner and much larger
numbers but he's totally protected by
the department of Injustice and by
the fake news media which has been
weaponized to a degree we have never
ever seen before
this is a crime 100 times bigger than
Watergate and they just don't want to
write about it
when I get back
in office
I will appoint a real special prosecutor
to investigate every detail of the Biden
crime family of corruption
so incredible
and again out of respect for the office
of President I would never be talking
this way even knowing a lot of this
stuff
I have too much respect for the office
but once they do what they did to me and
to you by doing what they did so corrupt
I said now the gloves are off from that
standpoint what they've done is so
terrible so I'll speak differently than
I would have three weeks ago because you
never heard me use this kind of language
I wouldn't want to out of respect for
our country and for the office but uh we
we really have no choice these people
are sick they're sick people
but despite all of this they go after me
for the presidential records act well
that's what they should be looking at
because everything I did was under the
presidential records act we have a thug
prosecutor
named Smith Jack Smith he's a thug he's
had many losses he's destroyed many
lives and they put him in charge in the
meantime what about Biden's records this
guy has 1850 boxes he has boxes stored
in Chinatown in DC rough plays by the
way
he has them stored at Penn where China
has paid them almost a hundred million
dollars China paid over a hundred almost
a hundred million dollars and nobody
wants to even talk about that he took
classified information when he was a
Senator and even Democrat Senators say
you can't do that
charging a former president of the
United States under the Espionage Act of
1917 Espionage me espionage
as Putin said you are the most vicious
president ever there's never been a
president that did this to me and yet I
got along with him isn't it
don't forget I ended his pipeline first
day I ended it I said no more pipelines
in the middle of construction Biden came
in and he approved it
I gave javelins remember this I gave
javelins to Ukraine they were the
anti-tank missiles and they knocked the
hell out of Russia but I got along with
Putin and it's good to get along with
people on the other side it's very good
the Espionage Act of 1917 is an act for
a crime so heinous that only the death
penalty would do is one of the most
outrageous and vicious legal theories
ever put
in an American
court of law there's never been anything
like this and by the way almost all
other presidents took the documents with
them you look at Barack Hussein Obama
did anyone ever hear of Barack who said
about
the bushes took documents Jimmy Carter
took documents
you don't like
yeah I don't understand that I mean he
got us into the Middle East didn't he
huh got us into the Middle East
10 trillion dollars that's right no more
war unless we need it we we have the
greatest military now in the world I
rebuilt it of course we shouldn't have
given
85 billion dollars worth to Afghanistan
losing 13 great soldiers leaving
Americans behind that's what showed the
weakness and that's one of the reasons I
think maybe a primary reason that Putin
went into that presidency of China is
talking pretty big
the Espionage Act has been used to go
after Traders and spies that has nothing
to do with a former president legally
keeping documents
as a president the law that applies to
this case is not the Espionage Act this
vicious never used before never it's
only been used to me over boxes
that I'm allowed to have the Espionage
Act
but the presidential records Act
which is not even mentioned in this
horrible and vicious and stupid
according to very talented lawyers
44-page indictment under the
presidential records act which is a
civil
situation not a criminal law I had every
right to have these documents personal
belongings and boxes I had absolute
right to have them Joe Biden didn't and
Mike Pence didn't and neither did
certain other people that were in
presidents because they were not covered
by the presidential records Act of 1978
relatively new compared to others but
these Scoundrels and thugs in our
weaponized government are corrupt just
like the president is corrupt
so they've decided only to come after me
only to come after me it's an amazing
thing it's called election interference
and it's backfired on them
because my poll numbers are much higher
now than they were
three months ago
and we were still leading by a lot three
months ago but now we're really leaning
a lot of people are going to start
dropping out watch you know they're in a
solid one one of them had a zero with an
arrow to the left what does that mean
can you have a zero with an arrow
pointing left that means they got less
than zero I guess it's probably a double
voter you know these people to vote two
three four times I guess that's what
they're referring to they have zero with
a narrow pointing left
The crucial legal precedent is laid out
in the most important case ever on this
subject known as the Clinton Sox case
you know why because he took things out
in his socks
Bill Clinton after leaving the White
House Bill Clinton kept 79 audio tapes
in his socks and his sock draw
unusual place right of these tapes some
of the most important conversations in
government were had talked to the
leaders of many many
big and great and strong and countries
enemies of ours A lot of them Not only
was Bill Clinton never even considered
for criminal prosecution based on the
tapes
and all of the other things he took but
the tapes in particular they were brutal
but when he was sued for them in a civil
case he won the case
judge in other words they said he could
do a Judge Amy Berman Jackson's decision
States I quote under the statutory
scheme established by the presidential
records act the decision to segregate
personal materials from presidential
records is made by the president during
the president's term and in his soul and
complete discretion
you're getting this in other words it's
a phony deal
any normal Administration even an
opposing one would consider that to be
the end of the case but not the corrupt
Biden regime because they want to do
this for election interference he's
getting his ass kicked in the polls and
he needs to do this for election
interference which is their new form of
cheating
it's actually a pretty old form but it's
new to this country to the extent that
they're doing it the Sox decision also
States quote
the National Archives and Records
Administration or Nara radical left
group you know they have Nara has the
Constitution flagged red flagged you
know that and they have not only the
Constitution red flag they have the Bill
of Rights because they say that the
dangerous documents this is what we're
dealing with
but they don't have the authority to
designate think of that Nara does not
have the authority to designate
materials as presidential records
they're the ones coming after me Nara
does not have the tapes in question and
error lacks any right Duty or means to
seize control of them this is the
decision of the judge
the president enjoys unconstrained
Authority this is again the decision of
a respected judge to make decisions
regarding the disposition of documents
neither the archivist nor Congress has
the authority to veto the president's
decision in other words the president
alone not the vice president not allowed
not other offices and not the Senators
when he was a Senator he took a lot of
classified information and you're not
allowed to do that the presidential
records Act is not confer any at all
mandatory or even discretionary
Authority
on the archivist to classify records
under the statute just to finish up this
responsibility is left solely to the
president of the United States not all
these other people that say oh he kept
some documents
what I do I do legally in other words
whatever documents a president decides
to take with him he has the absolute
right to do so that's the law and it
couldn't be more clear I don't think it
could be more clear than that
even the New York Times of all papers in
a major article said that when it comes
to asking for documents I guarantee you
this reporter got fired
from the former presidents the only
Power that Nara has is to say pretty
please this is the times pretty pleased
could we have them quote asking nicely
is about all they can do and yet they
reported me to the Department of Justice
for criminal prosecution so there it is
nothing like this has ever happened the
Espionage Act has never been used before
these are sick people these are
degenerates that are running our country
and our country is going to hell
and I just might add briefly you know
right next door because these are all
Democrats and they're all in total
contact
they're in total contact with the
justice department that includes
Manhattan that includes Atlanta Georgia
one of the most unsafe
per capita places anywhere in this
country it's number one or number two
worse than Chicago you don't know that
people are leaving Atlanta
and we loved Atlanta we love Georgia
Georgia was we did great in Georgia
unfortunately bad things happen we can't
let any of that stuff happen again and
we're not going to let it but in right
next door in Georgia the racist district
attorney goes after me for a perfect
phone call even more perfect than the
call I made to Ukraine even more perfect
she's got the worst per capita crime
record in the country murders
think of this murders are allowed to get
away with murder
they're allowed to get away with murder
they don't even go after them the only
one they go after is Trump let's say
didn't he have a phone call
and when you think about that call many
lawyers were in that call that was a
call made when I was president and I was
protesting the election results in
Georgia
and they had numerous many that
Secretary of State on raffensberger and
they had many lawyers on the call some
ours but many of them theirs not one
person protested that call there was no
problem with that call they didn't say
sir I'm sorry please rephrase it was
only a long time afterwards they said
let's see Trump made a phone call didn't
he
well we actually made another one that
was so perfect that they refused to even
show it or report it but we have a copy
of it it was a perfect call these were
perfect calls these were calls where
you're questioning the validity
and the safety of Elections
and it's a disgrace that they're allowed
to even think about it but not one
person protested until long after that
call
and if there was something wrong with
that call I am not a stupid person
number one I'm an honest person so I
wouldn't do it anyway but when people
are on the phone including many lawyers
do you think many people were on that
phone
many many people do you think I'm going
to say what they'd like to have but the
problem is
it's not borne out I will tell you what
is borne out the call was supposedly
taped in the State of Florida and on
Florida you're not allowed to do you
know that's a two-party state in other
words you're not allowed to take phone
calls they taped the phone code to show
you how nice they are they taped the
phone call and you're not allowed so
that is the real crime here they had a
two-party state with somebody taping the
call supposedly from Florida the bidens
took in millions and millions of dollars
from Ukraine from Russia and from China
and now Joe has given China the green
light as they open up not even
believable military installations in
Cuba just 90 miles off our Coast think
of that
and that will end as soon as I'm
president China will be leaving
[Applause]
they will be leaving and we had a very
good relationship you didn't hear about
Taiwan and you didn't hear about Ukraine
from Putin during my four years they say
how do you know because that would have
never happened they say how do you know
they say because number one it never
happened was never even discussed they
knew better Joe Biden's policy is China
first my policy is very simple America
first
[Applause]
and by the way is everybody warm enough
are you sure
but this is South Carolina we used a
nice beautiful warm weather
how about Joe when he's in Florida he
goes it's really nice to be in New
Hampshire they got palm trees up or when
he was in Ohio
no how about Iowa
well actually the best the best happened
to be
when he said last couple of days what he
was saying about Ukraine and Iraq but
when he's in a certain State many times
he's got that wrong it's wonderful to be
in Iowa sir sir it's Idaho oh Idaho
they grow potatoes in Idaho right
now we got a man who's grossly
incompetent and and he could get us into
World War III and this will not be a war
like army tanks going back and forth
shooting at each other these are weapons
so powerful it's obliteration
he shouldn't be there he shouldn't be
there shouldn't be there for a lot of
reasons but he shouldn't be there just
based on his confidence and tell him to
take the cognitive test that would be an
interesting
set a record for an all-time I took it
you know they said Trump is vicious and
he's brilliant that he wants to take
over the world and that wasn't working
then they said Trump is this Trump is
that then they said well Trump's let's
see oh he must be stupid always stupid
so when I heard that I said let me take
the cognitive test and I did
given and administered by a whole lot of
doctors and
Dr Ronnie Jackson of Texas who is now a
congressman was an admiral great
and as he said to everybody Trump aced
it I aced it I got him all right
and you know I never heard the stupid
stuff anymore so that one disappeared so
I think Biden should take it that way he
can get rid of that
they can get rid of that little
statement about him being not so smart
despite the Biden's flagrant corruption
the weaponized Department of Injustice
interfered to block the investigation
against Joe and Hunter stop felony
charges and even
secretly tipped off Hunter this just
came out recently about a search of his
storage units just a little different
than what they did with the gun toting
FBI agents when they rate it
Mar-A-Lago
well Joe Biden used the doj to cover up
his own crimes he ordered his top
political opponent me arrested they
arrested me right in the middle of our
presidential election which Joe Biden is
losing by a lot
by a lot
they rigged the presidential election in
2020 we're not going to allow them to
rig the presidential election of 2024.
never forget
our enemies want to stop me because I am
the only one who can stop them
if these corrupt persecutions of our
people succeed
they will complete the Takeover of this
country
this country will be taken over by these
lunatics and destroy your way of life
forever
and you know when that happens there's
no coming back it'll be gone
communism remember I used to use the
word socialism they passed that station
a long time ago
communism
their fascists marxists they want to
take away my freedom because I will
never let them take away your freedom I
will never let it happen
they want to silence me because I will
never let them silence you
and in the end
they're not after me they're after you
and I just happen to be standing in
their way it's an honor to do so
and it's no wonder the swamp is getting
truly desperate because as we do better
and better and up old numbers rock it
they get more and more vicious they have
all these vicious thugs just vicious
horrible thoughts in the new premise
poll
we are at 59 and that's with all of
these people running we have a massive
lead in the Siena poll
we're at 61 percent
the Republican primary vote against how
many people are running now every day it
gets bigger and bigger in the Harvard
Harris poll we're leading by 45 points
in another poll by upholster who I just
spoke to in the back we're up 61 points
on everybody 61.
that's a lot
in the national public affairs poll here
in South Carolina
we are leading by many many points in
fact so points so many points they
didn't even want to put out a number
they said
they said whatever the hell it is and
you have as you know Tim Scott who
happens to be a good man by the way but
you have Tim Scott and you have Nikki
Haley
running
but leading by so much that people don't
even want to put out the numbers they
don't even believe them
and we're leading Biden by many six
percent in the Harvard Harris but
remember
you would hear six percent is out for a
republican that's considered a landslide
because they start off number one they
start off cheating like hell okay forget
that but they start off with lots of
people that I don't think are going to
vote for them anymore like unions like
Civil Service like others they have an
automatic base of probably 35 percent
the Republicans don't have that base we
have to win the entire
East Coast like I did we won Florida
we won Georgia we won
2016 we won everything we ran up the
east coast and all of a sudden we won a
state that hadn't been won in many many
many years the state of
the not the stake we run a wonderful
beautiful
place did anyone ever hear of
Pennsylvania Pennsylvania we won
Pennsylvania
we won Pennsylvania by a lot and we want
to we just we just ran the board and
they had things going on but we won by
so much the key to this is you have to
win you have to swamp them if you can
swamp them okay if you can swap them
you're going to win by
tremendous because at a certain level
they can't cheat but remember when you
have open border policies no voter ID
policies high taxes High interest rates
uh no longer energy
sufficient we don't have enough energy
in our country and yet we have more
Liquid Gold
think of it we have more Liquid Gold
under our feet than any other country in
the world including Saudi Arabia and
Russia
think of it
we have we were at a level where
gasoline was at numbers that nobody
could even believe 2024 is the most
important election in the history of our
country I used to say it with
2016. I didn't think I had to say it
with 2020 because we thought we were
going to win easily
the American workers she said you did
win you're right about that Bobby
[Applause]
to American workers watching their
take-home pay shrink and watching
inflation destroy their family and their
lives
to overtack small business owners
to the voiceless unborn child
to parents scared to death
that one of their children will become
the next fentanyl victim
by the way drugs are up at the border
almost 10 times from what they were just
three years ago
two teachers you're right there is no
border
we had a strong border with the
strongest Border in history now we have
I think the worst border anywhere in the
world no country would allow it to
happen what's happening to us to the
teachers who simply want to educate our
children not indoctrinate them
to the female student athlete who awakes
at five in the morning to train day
after day but is forced to compete
against male athletes
to our veterans
being denied the care
your country promised them
I mean look at what's happened to the
veterans administration since I've been
out we had the most pop 92 percent
approval rating now it's down in the 40s
what they've done to the veterans
administration is disgraceful to
families who are seeing their religious
freedom under attack and the seniors
living in fear
their social security benefits and
Medicare
being drastically cut to all of you I
have your back none of this will happen
we have your back
America is tired of being ruled
by the radical bureaucrats and we are
done with the likes of the bidens that
clintons the radical left Democrat
Communists Marxist fascists
the Obama's Paul Ryan and Karl Rove
almost as bad they have bad news I
promise you this if you put me back in
the White House their reign will be over
in the America
that we knew and we knew for a long time
will indeed be a free Nation once again
it will be a free Nation
we're thrilled to be joined tonight by a
very special man in fact there are some
people that say I gave Nikki that
position at the United Nations because I
wanted your Lieutenant Governor to
become governor uh and I will not debate
them on that because I don't think I
could win that debate
because he's been an incredible Governor
he's a fantastic man Henry McMaster
[Applause]
and Mrs McMaster thank you what a woman
what a woman
they worked so hard for me
they endorsed me from day one and he
went around the state they both did
really went around the state uh day in
day out he said sir you're going to win
you're going to win well I'm running
against you Governor he said you're
going to win and we really won but I had
the advantage of you and my opponent
only had the advantage of Nikki so we
like we like Henry I know I've always
loved him and you're doing a fantastic
job as Governor that I've heard from
everybody fantastic
and again Senator Lindsey Graham who is
really God I'm gonna have to work
I'm gonna have to work on these people
all right
he's he's
there he's there when you need him today
I'm gonna get him straightened up do you
mind if I come here and campaign a
little bit for you he I'll tell you what
he was one of my earliest endorsements
right from the go and I appreciate it
very much I appreciate it does it
lieutenant governor Pamela event thank
you thank you Pamela you're doing a
great job
Treasurer Curtis Loftus
[Applause]
Congressman William Timmons who's really
been Fanta where's William he's around
here someplace I just saw him
William Timmons has been great
Congressman who's really a star this is
a shooting star Russell Frye where's
Russell
what a job Russell's done
thank you Russell
congressman
or as I call her she's both
the strongest person you've ever met and
she is smart as hell I don't know if she
gets credit for that I'm not so sure
Governor but uh let me tell you she's
smart she's tough she can do things that
other people can't
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green
[Applause]
and former lieutenant governor very
popular guy
Andre Bauer thank you Andre for being
here with your family
as well as state representatives Thomas
Beech Stuart Jones
Patrick Hadden
Cal Forest Doug Gilliam David O'Neill
Melissa Lackey harmless and J kilmartin
along with
[Applause]
who are fantastic and thank you all very
much for the endorsement and Jimmy thank
you very much mayor Pro tem Jimmy Davis
all these people endorse me the
presidents who want to cover it if they
endorse the other guys that are down at
two or three there'd be headlines we
have headlines
but they all endorsed me and I
appreciate it very much many many
endorsements including from you governor
including from your governor and your
Senator I also want to introduce the
South Carolina chapter of moms for
Liberty
thank you very much
[Music]
they have the best seat in the house
actually
and Pickens police chief a fantastic guy
he made this really happen this is a big
I don't know how many we have I heard 75
000 people are here it goes so far back
I cannot see the end unfortunately we
gave the fake news a better position so
they're blocking the view of people that
go block spec but it's big a lot of
people 75 000.
Pickens
police chief Randall Beach thank you
random
and you heard from him before the
rushing Brook Children's Choir who were
not treated properly they're here
so we want to thank those incredible
children with those beautiful voices
I wish I had a voice like them
today our campaign is also pleased to
announce the endorsements of over 250
Grassroots leaders representing all 46
counties in South Carolina that's a lot
that's a lot what's left is there
anything left 250 I mean how big is your
legislature how many politicians you
have although you do love politics in
the state heavy
in four incredible years under our
Administration we achieved more than any
president in our lifetime so many people
say that everybody's saying that even
the crazy Democrats are saying it we
deliver the largest tax cuts and
Regulatory Cuts in history and likewise
we built the greatest economy in the
history of the world there's never been
an economy
like what we built we were lapping China
China paid us hundreds of billions of
dollars nobody else got 10 cents we
achieved energy Independence and energy
dominance was just around the corner
first time in at least 72 years we had
gas prices at
1.87 cents a gallon and even lower than
that in some months
after years of Washington betrayals of
South Carolina workers I ended the
disaster known as NAFTA the worst trade
deal ever made not even believable
and replaced it with the usmca the best
trade deal ever made for our country
although I would say the deal we made
with China might even be better they
take 50 billion dollars a year but you
know what I don't even mention it
anymore because of kovid what they did
to us in covet what they did to the
world in covid
the deal was so good the usmca in fact
that Mexico and Canada are now trying to
renegotiate it with the Biden
Administration how much will they pay
him do you think how much will he get
don't do it Biden don't do it the Biden
administration because we suffered
we suffered with the worst trade deal
ever we suffered for years and now we
have one that's so good that they want
to renegotiate it I knew that because I
made I made the deal that some great
people Bob Lighthouse or some others we
had some great people I stood up to
China like no Administration has ever
done before I exposed China bringing in
hundreds of billions of dollars in taxes
and tariffs pouring into our Treasury
now while coming out of China hundreds
of billions of dollars when no other
president had done anything and exposed
China as being an Empire that is not
very kind to us a lot of people didn't
know they said oh isn't it wonderful
and when China targeted our Farmers I
gave our farmers
28 billion dollars straight out of the
tariffs that I took in for China so the
farmers got 28 billion so when people
say that Rhonda sanctimonious is doing
fine with the farmers no he's not
he's not he's actually getting
absolutely destroyed he's he's getting
destroyed he's so low in Iowa but after
you give 28 billion dollars to the
farmers I said you think a farmer is
voting against me I don't think so
but the Sanctus opposed my China tariffs
and he opposed helping our Farmers he
didn't want to allow that deal to be
made gave him 28 billion and he didn't
want it to happen and he's doing
horribly by the way in Nebraska and Iowa
we created the most secure Border in U.S
history built nearly 500 Miles aboard a
wall got Mexico to give us 28 000
soldiers free of charge
Mr president we'd like to have your
soldiers to protect our border I said no
no no you cannot no no we have to have
that no no no you will never get that I
said yes I will 100 I'll get it no no no
I said well then I'm going to be putting
a tariff of 25 on all cars coming into
the United States made in Mexico which
used to be made in the United States and
it's going up from there we would love
to give you 28 000 so would you like
some more was an amazing negotiation but
it gave us the strongest border that we
ever had and that was just three years
ago and now you look at what's happening
they're back to catch and release they
catch them and they release them in
their in our country and they say come
back just come back in four or five
years for a child nobody comes back
because they're too smart to come back
and deported illegal alien gang members
by the thousands and thousands MS-13 by
the thousands of tens of thousands we
got them out now they leave them in our
country we appointed nearly 300 federal
judges and three great Supreme Court
Justices
and this week those Justice's rule to
move our
country forward
with a merit-based system of Education
how big is that
isn't that big isn't that great
in other words if you're a worker and
you worked very hard in school
you got fantastic marks somebody that
hasn't done nearly as well who perhaps
has not worked nearly as hard will not
be taking your place on a school college
or at a university they're not going to
be we're going by Merit we're back to
the old Merit system that built our
country that was a big one that was a
big one and then yesterday the Supreme
Court also ruled that President Biden is
not allowed to wipe out hundreds and
hundreds of billions probably trillions
of dollars in student loan debt which
would have been very unfair to the
millions and millions of people
who have paid their debt through hard
work and diligence they paid their debt
off like that man right there right they
paid it off and now somebody's going to
get
free rides no they ruled against it 100
against it amazing and they also gave
religious liberty a tremendous win you
know that
not to mention the fact that one year
ago they ruled against Roe v Wade
something said never going to happen
and you have to know how to discuss this
giving pro-lifers a tremendous power to
negotiate and moving this issue back to
the states where legal Scholars and
almost all others think it should be but
we now have an absolute power to
negotiate we didn't have that power and
people that believe in life will be able
to stop radical left Democrats from
killing babies in their fifth sixth
seventh eighth ninth month and even
killing babies after birth
[Applause]
because they are the radical ones you
know they want to sell it differently
they are the radical ones anyone that
wants to
take a baby in the fourth month or the
fifth month or the ninth month or even
after you remember the former governor
of Virginia
the baby is born and then we decide what
to do with it would kill the baby after
birth
that's a great issue the Republicans
have to understand that issue better
they have to speak about it better have
to speak about it better that was a big
big win
for years they were trying 50 years
they've been trying to get it I got it
done and it's a great issue for us but
more importantly from the standpoint of
the heart
from the standpoint of your soul it is
what you believe in so you now have a
great power to negotiate before with Roe
v Wade you had no power at all I fully
rebuilt the US military created space
force defeated Isis and brought our
troops all back home we started no world
in fact I was the first president in
many decades who didn't start a war
and for Israel I kept my promise
recognized its Eternal Capital opened
the American Embassy in Jerusalem and
recognized Israeli sovereignty over the
Golan Heights
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much I love you too I
love you too
[Applause]
we've got a country that's failing
though we have to solve the problem we
have to solve it in 2024 but most
importantly with Israel except they blew
it we would have had a deal with Iran
Within literally minutes after the
election
but the election was rigged and now Iran
is trying to create a nuclear weapon but
we would have had a deal they were dying
to make a deal I stopped China and
everybody else from buying oil from them
Biden hasn't done anything and we're in
very grave position with what's going on
that was one of the worst deals ever
made and now they're willing to make an
even worse deal
this Administration I always fought for
South Carolina including by delivering
millions and millions to
your great Governor Henry McMaster to
ensure that Charleston has the deepest
water port
on the East Coast the deepest water Port
Henry right
how about the West Coast we have to go a
little deeper let's go a little deeper
Henry come on let's make it in the
country we'll go deeper
but all of that was only the beginning
here is just some of the Bold agenda
that I'll immediately Implement when we
become we we become the 47th president
of the United States
before I even arrive at the Oval Office
shortly after
by win the presidency because of you I
will have the horrible war between
Russia and Ukraine settle I'll get it
done in 24 hours I know them both very
well
zielinski and Putin I'll get itself very
very quickly should have never started
should never have started all of those
people that have been killed would be
alive today all of those cities that are
just absolutely demolished would be up
would be prosperous I am the only
candidate who can make this promise and
the promise is I will prevent World War
III nobody else is going to be able to
do it
[Music]
I will totally obliterate the Deep State
we will find the globalists warmongers
and the bureaucrats who have weaponized
our justice system and we will escort
them from federal buildings we're going
to get them the hell out of government
I will end the disaster
known as bidenomics he doesn't even know
two weeks ago they used the term he said
what is that now he likes the term I
guess you know what it means it means
destruction for our company that's
that's Destruction for our country
we will replace Biden's tax sites with
the beautiful Trump tax cuts you know we
have to extend the tax cuts biggest tax
cuts in history I will cancel every
Biden regulation that's harming South
Carolina workers and there are many and
they're coming into being every single
day we will stop Biden's inflation
Nightmare and I will reverse every one
of Biden's globalist economic betrayals
and once again we will put America First
and we'll put it first like never before
[Applause]
to protect South Carolina workers and
manufacturers I will pass the Trump
reciprocal trade act which I have one
vote right here already and he said to
me gee that sounds good you mean one for
one but we had some Senators that I
don't think either they
had a deal made or they didn't
understand it but it's an incredible
thing as an example of India China or
another country hits us with a 100
percent or 200 percent tariff any tariff
at all we will hit them with the exact
same tariff right back
and they will either withdraw or we're
going to take a lot of money in I mean
we have cases many cases and I'm not
just talking about China the European
Union is brutal where they tax us and we
don't tax them and we're all set to do
it until we got hit with covid then we
had other things to do unlike Rhonda
sanctimonious who voted to gut Medicare
and Social Security and voted three
times to raise the retirement age to 70
Ron voted to retake and you deserve that
you know you you deserve
what that says you worked all your life
in many cases nobody's going to mess
around with it he wanted to raise it to
70. that wasn't the deal I will always
protect Medicare and social security for
our great seniors and in four years
I never discussed it
and one thing about a politician when
they bring it up
and if they bring it up they'll bring it
up again
to stop the Marxist prosecutors who
release rapists and murderers while
persecuting conservatives and by the way
the Catholic church is under siege by
these people so I don't know how any
Catholic or any Christian could vote for
I will direct a
completely overhauled doj to investigate
every radical D.A in America for their
illegal racist and reverse enforcement
of the law
I will immediately terminate every open
borders policy of the Biden
Administration and bring it back to what
it was just three years ago strongest
border
[Applause]
and under Biden
other countries are emptying out their
prisons their mental institutions and
dumping everyone
including terrorists big big scale
terrorists into the USA congratulations
a lot of people have asked me
for the parody of what we call the snake
did anyone ever hear the snake
did you ever hear that Lindsay the snake
Marjorie you've heard it plenty
does anybody want me to do the snake
now you know it is very hot it'll take a
minute but it is hot who wants this
snake
who doesn't want the snake
nobody let's go
so this is
this is I don't really need it actually
I don't really know this we we remember
things pretty well
but this is about our border this is
about what's happening this is about the
treachery of what's happening on our
border and the people that are coming in
and countries aren't sending their best
they're sending people that are as you
know and as I said in jails and mental
institutions insane asylums it's a
horrible thing horrible thing that's
happening and I believe the real number
is going to be 15 million people by the
end of this year Henry so it's going to
be terrible
on her way to work one morning
down the path along the lake
a tenderhearted woman saw a poor hair
Frozen snake his pretty colored skin had
been all frusted with the Dew
poor thing she cried I'll take you in
and I'll take care of you
take me in oh tender woman Take Me In
For Heaven's Sake take me in O tender
woman Inside The Vicious snake
she wrapped him up all cozy in a
comforter of silk and laid him by her
Fireside with some honey and some milk
she hurried home from work that night
and as soon as she arrived she found the
pretty snake she'd taken
had been fully fully fully revived take
me in O tender woman Take Me In For
Heaven's Sake take me in O tender woman
inside the vicious snake she clutched
him to her bosom you're so beautiful she
cried
but if I hadn't brought you in by now
you truly would have died
she stroked his pretty skin again and
kissed and held him tight but instead of
saying thank you ma'am
the snake gave her a vicious bite
take me in O tender woman Take Me In For
Heaven's Sake
take me an otender woman Inside The
Vicious snake
I saved you
cried the woman
and you've bitten me but why
you know your bite is poisonous and now
I'm going to die shut up
silly woman
said the reptile
with a grin you knew damn well I was a
snake
before you took me in
I think
I think it's pretty good
[Applause]
give it to somebody
we'll see it on eBay tonight ten
thousand
but that's our border that's what it is
we're being misled and it's vicious and
violent and criminals are coming in and
these countries are very smart I know
every one of I know the leaders they're
very Street wise people smart people and
they're sending us their problems and
we're going to take we're taking in
millions of problems
when I'm back in office following the
Eisenhower model we will use Arrow every
necessary
State local Federal and Military
resource to carry out the largest
domestic deportation in American history
starting with the criminals
starting with
some very very bad criminals many many
criminals murderers
many many many criminals to further
deter illegal immigration I will sign a
day one on day one executive order
ending automatic citizenship for the
children of illegal aliens they come
here
illegally they have children we're the
only country in the world that does that
they come in they have children and now
the children you say welcome aboard
and then they bring their parents in
with them later we're the only country
in the world that does it Henry
in addition to
build on the historic progress we made
at implementing strict vetting for all
immigrants I will order our government
to deny entry to all Communists and
marxists as required by law
our bigger problem is what about the
Communist marxists and fascists that
have been here for a long time
the ones that are partially running our
government we got to get them to hell
out too
I will immediately sign a new executive
order to cut Federal funding for any
school pushing critical race Theory
transgender and settlement
and any other inappropriate racial
sexual or political content
to our children
I will keep men out of women's sports
and I'm the one that started that they
owned by wonderful brilliant people that
work with sir I'd rather not have you
bring that up this is like two years ago
I'd rather not have you bring that up
they'd say Marjorie sir you know a
consultant they get paid all this money
they don't know a thing
and frankly uh whether they want it or
not it's wrong and it's so demeaning to
women so to women so horrible for women
you saw the other day the weight lifter
19 years this record and the woman was a
great champion
they put a quarter of an ounce on one
side
of the barbells a quarter of an ounce
quarter of an ounce on the other
and she did everything she could I'll do
it in the heat it's hot as hell out here
by the way
hot as hell
but we have to keep going we have to
trudge forward who the hell cares you go
home take a nice cold shower you'll be
fine right
but she took those barbells and she
lifted them and her parents were there
and her future husband was there and
they were going to watch her break the
record by just a little tiny bit stood
for 19 years
then she got up and she almost had it
but she couldn't do it
and then comes a nice sky
who's now transgender
they said have you lifted before no not
really
have you had any experience with weight
lifting no not much
well it's your turn good luck oh thank
you very much
being
that was the end of that contest
and they beat the records by many many
many
pounds it is so unfair and degrading
for women
and you know the amazing thing because
of our crazy woke society and I hate the
word woke actually because nobody even
has a real accurate description it was a
lack of Common Sense more than anything
else but because of
[Applause]
because of that because of these people
the even the participants are afraid to
talk about it
and as you know I didn't do mandates and
will never have a vaccine or a mask
mandate we never did
I Didn't Do It other people did and we
will protect and have protected our
Second Amendment I will defend innocent
life like nobody has ever done before
nobody's ever done that 50 years and we
got it and now you're in a position to
negotiate something really big because
of what we did
I will bring back free speech in America
and I will move Heaven and Earth to
fully secure our elections we have to
secure
we have open borders
and we have really bad
and corrupt elections and therefore we
almost don't have a country and soon you
won't have a country if you keep that up
our goal will be one day voting with
only paper ballots
and voter ID in all cases
but until then Republicans must compete
using every lawful means to win
we will restore patriotic education to
our schools and we will teach our
children to love our country
to honor our history
and always salute our Great American
flag
and we will teach them
the legend of the great General
Andrew Pickens
nearly six years into the American
Revolution the cause of the Patriots was
looking very very Bleak it was looking
bad looked like they couldn't do it one
by one the Redcoats were laying waste to
Southern territories they were taking
over vast amounts of land
but then the enemy made a fatal error
they came
for us
the back country they came to the back
that was not a good move the backcountry
does anybody know what the back country
is because I do
how many people are from the back
country yes
they made a bad mistake they came to the
back country of South Carolina
and despite long odds of Victory he was
given no chance Pickens urge says South
Carolina Patriots to stand strong and
stand Brave at the historic Battle of
Cowpens just 60 miles from here the
enemy was fooled into believing the
Americans were in retreat
but General Pickens would never Retreat
and the people that knew him knew that
and he would never ever surrender the
British forces were decimated and the
Patriots won a stunning Victory one of
the most important victories to our
freedom
and to our glorious Independence like
General Pickens all of us here today
are in a battle for American Liberty and
Independence and like the great General
We Must Stand Tall we must stand strong
and we must charge forward to Victory we
have to do it we're doing this is the
same and I've been saying people would
ask me who's our biggest enemy is it
China
could it be Russia could it be North
Korea what about Iran I said no no no
our biggest
enemy is from within they're sick people
from within the Communists the marxists
the fascists
because if we have the right person
running like I was no Wars no threats of
Wars no Russia going into Ukraine no
China talking about Taiwan wasn't even
think about wasn't on the table because
if we have the right person but what do
they do they impeach him twice they go
after him like nobody's ever been gone
after and the people of this country
will not stand for it any longer from
Greenville to Great Falls from Colombia
to Clemson and from Charleston to right
here with all of you
we stand on the
shoulders of generations of American
Patriots who gave everything they had
for our country and for our freedom our
American ancestors conquered a dangerous
Frontier they tamed the Wilderness they
fought the battles they face down the
enemies
and they poured out their Blood Sweat
and Tears
to make this into the greatest nation in
the history
of the world
[Music]
[Applause]
but now
we are a nation in Decline
we are a failing Nation
we are a nation that has the highest
inflation in 50 years
where banks are collapsing and interest
rates have gone through the roof
likewise we are a nation where energy
costs have reached the highest in our
history
we are no longer energy independent or
energy dominant
like we were just a few short years ago
we are a nation that is begging
Venezuela and many others
for oil please please please help us Joe
Biden says
yet we have more liquid gold right under
our feet than any other country
we are a nation that is consumed
by the radical left screen New Deal
yet everyone knows that the green New
Deal is fake
and will lead to our country's
destruction
we are a nation whose leaders are
demanding all electric cars
even though they can't go far
they cost too much
and whose batteries are produced in
China with materials only available in
China
when an unlimited amount of gasoline is
available inexpensively in the United
States but not available in China
we are a nation that ended oil
exploration and production in the U.S
just as the price of oil reached an
all-time high what other country would
do such a thing how could anybody be so
foolish
we are a nation that surrendered in
Afghanistan leaving behind dead soldiers
American citizens and 85 billion dollars
worth of the finest military equipment
anywhere in the world
and we are a nation that allowed Russia
to devastate a country Ukraine
killing hundreds of thousands of people
and it will only get worse under this
leadership
it would never have happened with me as
your president
and for four straight years it didn't
happen
and China with Torah
is next
that's right China
with Taiwan is next watch we are a
nation that has weaponized its law
enforcement against the opposing
political party like never before
we've got a Federal Bureau of
Investigation that won't allow bad
election-changing facts to be presented
to the public and which offers one
million dollars to a rider of fiction
about Donald Trump to lie and say it was
fact
where Hunter Biden's laptop from hell
was Russian disinformation
and the FBI knew it wasn't but 51
intelligence agents said it was and they
knew it wasn't also
and the Department of Justice that
refuses to investigate
egregious acts of voting irregularities
and fraud
and we have a man who is totally corrupt
and the worst president in the history
of our country
who is cognitively impaired
and in no condition to lead
and is now in charge of dealing with
Russia
and possible nuclear war which would be
World War III and far more devastating
than any of the previous Wars because of
the Weaponry that no one even wants to
think about
there is nothing like
the Weaponry of today
it will destroy everything
we are a nation that no longer has a
free and fair press fake news is all you
get and they are the enemy of the people
they refuse to discuss the Biden crime
family
but enjoy covering false indictments of
Donald Trump who has done absolutely
nothing wrong and almost all pundits say
so
we are a nation where free speech is no
longer allowed
and where crime is rampant and out of
control like never ever before
we are a nation that is allowing Iran to
build a massive nuclear weapon and China
to use the trillions and trillions of
dollars
it is taken from us
to build a military to rival or surpass
our own
and less than three years ago we had
Iran China Russia and North Korea in
check
they weren't going to do a thing against
us and everyone knows it they respected
us
and they respected your leader
now Russia and China
are holding Summits to carve up the
world
and perhaps most importantly we are a
nation that is no longer respected or
listened to in the world stage
we are a nation that in many ways has
become a joke
we are a nation that is hostile to
Liberty freedom and faith
we are a nation whose economy is
collapsing into a cesspool of ruin
whose supply chain is broken whose
stores are not stocked whose deliveries
are not coming and whose educational
system is ranked at the bottom of every
single list
we are a nation where large packs of
sadistic criminals and thieves are
allowed to go into stores and openly Rob
them
beat up and kill our workers and
customers and leave with arm loads of
goods but with no retribution or
retaliation
where the authority of our great police
has been taken and they are great
and where their families and pensions
have been threatened and their lives
would be destroyed for the mere mention
of the words law enforcement we are a
nation where Fentanyl and other forms of
illegal drugs are easier to get than
formula for our beautiful little babies
a nation who's once revered airports are
dirty
they're a crowded mess you sit and wait
for hours and then are notified that the
plane won't leave and they have no idea
when it will where ticket prices have
tripled they don't have the pilots to
fly the planes they don't seek qualified
air traffic controllers anymore and they
just don't know what they're doing
we are a nation that has lost its
confidence lost its willpower and lost
its strike
we are a nation that has lost its way
but we are not going to allow this
horror to continue three years ago we
were a great nation and we will soon be
a great nation again
[Applause]
it was hard-working Patriots like you
who built this country and it is
hard-working Patriots like you who are
going to save our country
2024 is our final battle
with your support
this primer
we are going to finish what we started
with you at my son
we will demolish the Deep State we will
drive out the globalists we will cast
out the Communists we will throw off the
slick
and very sick
political class that hates our country
and we will route the fake news media
will will defeat crooked Joe Biden and
we will drain the swamp in Washington
D.C once and for all
[Applause]
[Music]
like those great Patriots before us we
will not Bend we will not break
we will not yield
we will never give in we will never give
up
we will never ever back down together we
will
complete the mission
we will cross the finish line we will
rescue Freedom liberty and justice and
propel
that Spirit of July 4th 1776.
we will win a righteous and magnificent
Victory on November 5th
2024 the great silent majority is rising
like never before nobody has ever seen
this before ever ever ever
record Crowds Are massively before the
election nothing like this has ever
happened in our country and probably any
other country either
but under our leadership the Forgotten
men and women
will be forgotten no longer
We Are One movement one people one
family and one nation under God
and together
we will make America powerful again
we will make America wealthy again we
will make America strong again
we will make America proud again
we will make America
safe again and we will make America
great again thank you to South Carolina
thank you very much Pickens
thank you very much and have a happy
Fourth of July thank you everybody
[Applause]